welcome back to new rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse and venom 2 has given us our first
real look at carnage Cletus Kasady with
Woody Harrelson's britain garb and the
venom post-credit scene swapped out for
a look that makes you think I'll cross
the other side of the street believe it
or not this early raw imagery of carnage
actually has a lot of clues that connect
to recent carnage comics that shed a
buncha light on what horrible [ __ ] this
character will do in venom - I'm gonna
explain how this movie could take the
spider verse to a very dark place but
also one that could make the MCU
spider-man 3 even better we're learning
in case they get all this - right and
ruin your life ok hardy posted to
Instagram before abruptly taking him
down so you know it's a real sexy scoop
a photo of woody with the caption hello
Cletus fire emoji Cletus Kasady of
course is a serial killer Eddie Brock
interviewed Andy venom post-credit scene
get out of here and I will there's gonna
be carnage mmm carnage a bit on the nose
there I was really expecting it to be he
was gonna be just only Cena wasn't
already scooped up by James Gunn for
Suicide Squad anyway yes carnage in a
Marvel Comics carnage is a name Cletus
Kasady takes on after binding with his
symbiote offshoot from Eddie Brock when
they shared a prison cell together and
since this symbiote is attached to a
serial killer
compared to venom carnage is just a
purely evil brute with no moral code
whatsoever so Cletus Kasady was already
super sadistic before coming in contact
with the symbiote as a boy he murdered
his grandmother by pushing her down a
flight of stairs he tortured and killed
the family dog with a drill so yeah
great guy let's give him superhuman
symbiote powers so after escaping prison
carnage goes on a randomized killing
spree really carnage his reputation is
that of an extreme of viscerally savage
murderer who is so evil that venom has
to team up with spider-man just to stop
him now in the film's carnage his
appearance has changed from when we last
saw him in venom here he rocks a flashy
Hawaiian shirt and from his neck hangs a
skull like necklace
you know what detail were overlooking
here the hair they always take hair for
granted I know I do because I often
leave this thing a mess I give it no
thought whatsoever even though I'm
probably like a few years away from
losing it
all losing your hair is a bummer I know
friends and family that have to deal
with it we all want to stay youthful and
young looking forever and ever and keep
those luscious locks
well keeps has revolutionized the way
men are treated for hair loss with keeps
it's easier and more affordable to get
treatment for your hair loss and help
you keep the hair that you have keeps
treatments are up to 90% effective at
reducing and stopping further hair loss
find out why keep says more 5-star
reviews than any of its competitors and
nearly 100,000 men trust keeps for their
hair loss prevention medications keeps
treatment start at just $10 a month plus
for a limited time you can get 50% off
your first order if you're noticing that
you're losing your hair do something
about it for a limited time go do keeps
calm / new rock stars or click the link
in the description to receive 50% off
your first order we gotta talk about
clean it's Cassidy's hair before his
hair was curly dark red kind of Sideshow
Bob
esque now his hair is shorter and
straighter this look actually reflects
cletus's appearance in the carnage us a
comic run from 2011 and that story line
carnage spreads his violence to
small-town america he takes over the
town of doverton Colorado and turns all
the people there into a kind of cult
that worships him when we first see when
a comic his hair is shorter in
straighter and he wears a floral print
shirt just as he does at Hardee's set
photo so this could mean carnage USA
will be one of the comic inspirations
for carnage in this venom sequel like
perhaps we'll see carnage invade a
suburban home through the pipes of a
bathtub and bond to some poor kid but
actually Hardy's photo of carnage is one
of two looks that we got at this
character this week there was also a set
video showing a very short piece of a
scene with Cletus Kasady let's take a
look
yikes
I just hope this was shot for the movie
not you know Woody Harrelson himself
doing a weird little dance and then
getting shot at by a cop just luckily
his terrible aim but clearly this is a
shot of Cletus Kasady previa FEX so in
the final shot we'll probably see Cletus
his arm movement leading to an outgrowth
of tendrils of it's carnage symbiote as
it forms like a kind of protective
shield from the gunfire we did come up
with some darker more twisted ideas for
what could be happening here but we're
in our official discord that's the place
where all of our unfiltered discussions
have been happening with our inner
circle of supporters like our man Danny
pitched that carnage is grabbing the
bullets to mold them into a large blade
or scythe I pitched an idea that I'm not
too proud of see you join our disk or
today by becoming one of our patrons at
patreon.com slash new rock stars but
notice how in the background behind
Cletus there's an overhang sign for
Crosby apartments that might actually
tell us some key information Crosby
apartments is the name of a building in
San Francisco it's located on apparel
Street and via plug it into Google Maps
you can find at the street they actually
shot this scene on so this part of San
Francisco is called the Tenderloin
district scenario known for a large
homeless population plea this was last
seen in San Quentin prison near San
Francisco and if carnage is targeting
the city's homeless people that could
mean venom two might be drawing from the
carnage run in the Marvel Comics by
Donnie Cates the real recent one for the
past couple years
takes the characters to some very cool
places but also some real ones the
storylines we're talking about here are
the web of venom and absolute carnage
storylines
it's an insane crossover event that
establishes a new history and a religion
for the symbiotes like they were created
by a god named null and cletus kasady
kind of resurrects this church hoping to
become the new symbiote god the series
is great it ties in spider-man Miles
Morales Eddie Brock and his son Dylan
Brock Deadpool scream iron fist and
others and it features carnage at one
point splitting off worm-like pieces of
itself to infect the brains of homeless
people in San Francisco to create an
army of mind control drones now I would
be surprised to venom to when this deep
into the comics mythology of the
symbiotes and their religion
and a lot of these more recent carnage
comics have come out after the script
for venom 2 was likely locked in so I
don't know how much they could have
influenced the film that said there
really is no limit to the monstrosity of
cletus kasady like he seems to delight
in the sight of blood and what he
cleanest loves to say [ __ ] like I can
talk about the Dada's patterns of our -
yo spray I bet you can and say after
breaking out of San Quentin this monster
would definitely love to roam the
streets of San Francisco and kill anyone
in sight a bloodbath that might end in
this you know sexy little gunfire dance
and if this venom carnage film is taking
a page from the web of venom absolute
carnage crossover event it would be
interesting to see if they use this
venom sequel to bring in Tom Holland
Peter Parker or establish a live-action
Miles Morales in this universe yes the
characters do remain Sony properties but
the upcoming spider-man 3 will be
jointly Sony and part of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and I could
definitely see Kevin Feige who reports
say it's consulting on these venom films
pressuring Sony to set up a live-action
miles so that they could Beecher miles
in the next MCU spider-man story perhaps
as a kid that Peter Parker passes on the
mantle after losing his battle against
Kraven the hunter or sinister six or
wherever the villain ends up being in
the movie venom two could set that up
with venom and carnage his fight coming
to a kind of standstill leading to Eddie
returning in New York to seek the help
of another superpower - antihero we
recently accused Peter Parker spider-man
like a post-credits scene meet up in an
alley with some graffiti drawn by Miles
Morales you know you want to see it how
do you think venom 2 should set up the
next spider-man film comment down below
with your theories follow me on
instagram and twitter at me a box full
of new rock stars on social media
subscribe to new rock stars here on
YouTube for breakdowns of everything you
love thanks for watching and go ahead
fire those comments at me
[Music]